bonjour à tous bonjour herwan d'Anan
bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce matin
vous êtes effectivement député du
Finistère dans une circonscription très
rurale vers quin Perl et les syndicats
agricoles qui qui ont obtenu
satisfaction on le sait maintenant qui
on ont interrompu leur mouvement de
protestation il y a une victime
collatérale disent beaucoup c'est
l'écologie la mise en pause du plan
écopyo passe très mal chez les
défenseurs de l'environnement qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez je pense que ça
serait une erreur de continuer à opposer
les agriculteurs d'un côté les écologie
de l'autre euh moi sur mon territoire je
le vois bien avec les les contacts que
j'ai avec les agriculteurs ils sont tous
conscients des transitions nécessaires à
faire et on ne fera pas la transition
sur les territoires sans les
agriculteurs et il n'y aura plus
d'agriculture si on ne fait pas cette
transition donc c'est un travail qu'il
faut qu'on fasse ensemble et qu'il faut
peut-être revoir sur certains points le
plan écofyo aujourd'hui il marchait pas
très bien il est en pause jusqu'au salon
de l'agriculture et essayons de voir
comment on pe mie travaeruse monsieur
balanan on on recevait hier à votre
place marine Tondelier la la la la
patronne des vers qui disait bah
finalement les objectifs sont toujours
les mêmes mais quand on passe aux actes
et bien on les on les fait on les met en
pause pour pour obtenir une paix sociale
avec les agriculteurs oui mais c'est pas
la réalité du terrain la réalité du
terrain c'est qu'on a une agriculture
qui qui a déjà profondément changé moi
sur mon territoire les exploitations
elles ont changé
elles sont bien plus vertueuse vous avez
une décarbonation qui est en cours tout
ça est en cours alors pourquoi une pause
bah par parce que il y avait un mal un
malaise et quand vous avez une
population dans des territoires qui ne
ne comprend plus qui est entre
guillemets emmerdé par l'administration
parfois il faut revoir revoir les choses
et revoir les choses c'est pas c'est pas
baisser sur ces enjeux de la transition
je rappelle que ce budget de
l'agriculture il a été augmenté avec 1,3
milliards qui sont fléchés sur la
transition donc on va continuer en tout
cas moi député du finisterère je vais
tout faire pour que les deux
s'articulent par parfaitement vous
entendez aussi après ce conflit qui a
une sensation chez certains de deux
poids de mesure les agriculteurs ont
obtenu beaucoup finalement 400 millions
d'euros en bloquant les autoroutes en
sortant leur tracteur alors qu'il y a
beaucoup de catégories sociales qui
protestent pendant des semaines pendant
qui font également des actions parfois
violentes et qui n'obtiennent rien
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a pas quand
même effectivement de poids de mesure
non il y a pas de poids de mesure bon il
y a eu des quand il y a eu d'ailleurs ça
a fait créer un trouble quand il y a eu
des des choses qui étaient dans
l'illégalité avec des dégradations il y
a eu des il y a eu des gens qui ont été
interpellés le gouvernement a cédé mais
il a cédé non il a pas cédé il a écouté
c'est pas pareil pendant la crise covid
je vous rappelle que les entreprises
elles ont touché un certain nombre de
milliards parce qu'elles étaient
arrêtées aujourd'hui pendant ce temps-là
pendant la crise covid les agriculteurs
ils ont continué à travailler ils ont
continué à nourrir les français eux ils
ont pas été aidés alors qu'on les aide
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a une
situation difficiles des transitions à
mettre en œuvre ça me paraît assez
normal mais ça justifie donc ce cette
enveloppe de 400 milliards
ev
de fr la rédu de la dette onit que les
compes public français sont dans le
rouge d'où vient cet argent si on
abandonne l'agriculture aujourd'hui et
si on ne fait pas l'effort financier
maintenant ça nous coûtera plus cher
après donc soyons raisonnable entendons
ce malaise entendons la crise qui est
une crise profonde et avançons et
effectivement les enjeux financiers
restent des enjeux importants vous êtes
aussi membre donc de ce parti qui est
très
proeuropéen est-ce que c'est pas un peu
étrange de voir quand même des des
critiques y compris dans le camp
présidentiel donc sur Ben ces directives
qui viendraient de Bruxelles sur ce
besoin de souveraineté française c'est
est-ce qu'il y a pas on cherche pas un
bou émissaire à travers à travers
l'Europe et l'Union européenne ah moi je
suis persuadé que c'est tout le
contraire dans dans C les agriculteurs
vous les soutenez mais eux ils se
plaignent de non pas chez nous pas chez
moi et et et pas mal d'agriculteurs
partout en France sont très consci
beaucoup disent les problèmes les
problèmes viennent de l'Europe non il VI
non non ils disent pas ça ils disent les
problèmes viennent d'une
surinterprétation des des directives ici
chez nous où elles passent elles
arrivent à Paris elles sont remoulinées
elles arrivent ensuite dans les
préfectures de région elles sont de
nouveau moulinées et elles arrivent sur
le terrain et elles sont appliquées
parfois avec des façon qui sont parfois
asse éloigné de la directive initiale
donc c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on revoit
avec cet enjeu de protéger
l'environnement protéger les
agriculteurs leur donner un revenu et
faire en sorte que nos territoires
ruraux vivent bien bon on envent à la
situation donc de votre parti dans le
gouvernement parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
n'avez qu'un seul ministre alors excusez
du peu c'est celui de l'agriculture Marc
fen ça tombe bien mais est-ce que vous
attendez parce que ça fait maintenant 3
semaines que que presque un mois même
que Gabriel Atal a été nommé Premier
ministre et le gouvernement n'est
toujours pas au complet est-ce que le
modem attend d'être représenté à à la
hauteur de 51 députés qu'il contien dans
cette
majorité non je pense qu'aujourd'hui un
recentrage est nécessaire on l'a vu il y
a eu une inflexion un peu à droite en
tout cas une un sentiment d'avoir une
inflexion à droite sur ce sur ce premier
ce première liste gouvernementale je je
crois effectivement qu'il nous faut un
certain nombre de de députés ou pas
d'ailleurs de ministres
non oui mais c'est pas mon c'est pas je
suis un un parlementaire heureux et un
député heureux donc pas de souci mais
par contre oui il va falloir qu'on
rééquilibre ne serait-ce que pour
l'intérêt de la majorité parce que si on
veut qu'elle soit équilibrée qu'elle
fonctionne il faut que tous les courants
soient représentés vous dites euh c'est
unhémisme un virage un peu à droite
c'est-à- direire qu'est-ce qui vous a
choqué les nominations par exemple de
Rachid hadti de Catherine Vautrin qui
viennent de la droite à des postes
éminents du gouvernement j'ai j'ai dit
un ressenti un ressenti vous avez dit un
recentrage oui un recentrage et un
ressenti les deux vont bien ensemble non
moi j'ai pas de problème sur les
personnes en tant que telles elles vont
elles vont travailler on va voir et puis
madame Vautrin était déjà dans la
majorité depuis un moment la seule la
seule entre guillemets prise de guerre
c'est c'est Madame Datti on verra
comment elle elle va travailler et j'ai
l'impression que là pour le pour le
début c'est ses départs au ministère de
la Culture ça fonctionne plutôt bien
mais au-delà des nomination c'est un
c'est une politique aussi que vous avez
dénoncé au moment de la loi immigration
on a vu une majorité fissurée est-ce que
vous attendez et c'est pas du tout ce
qui est apparu notamment dans le
discours de politique générale de
Gabriel Atal effectivement ce recentrage
ce cette dédroitisation que que beaucoup
constatent alors moi moi je partage pas
votre ce que vous dites constat pas
complètement ça parce que sur le le
discours de politique générale du du du
Premier ministre moi j'ai trouvé queil y
avait beaucoup de sujets qui
rééquilibrai aussi les choses avec cette
idée de continuer à libérer les énergies
dans notre pays mais aussi partager la
valeur et aller vers plus de justice
sociale c'est ce qui nous intéresse et
c'est ce qui nous préoccupe en tout cas
au Mouvement démocrate il y a un
scénario en tout cas qu'on entend de
plus en plus c'est celui d'un retour
éventuel de François bairou dans ce
gouvernement pourquoi parce que lundi va
être con connu la décision du tribunal
de Paris sur l'affaire des emplois
présumés fictifs au Parlement européen
dans laquelle monsieur baayerou est
poursuivi mais il espère une relaxe
est-ce que vous vous souhaitez que votre
patron François baayerou revienne dans
un gouvernement on parle de lui à
l'éducation nationale il y a été il y a
il y a 30 ans ou voilà il a été il y a
30 ans et d'ailleurs il avait fait un
bon travail à l'éducation nationale
c'était
reconnu je suis pas sûr que ça soit sa
volonté donc moi je vais pas me
positionner à sa place en tout cas c'est
sûr que François Baayou ferit très bon
ministre de l'éducation nationale il
connaît parfaitement ses sujets il a une
vision sur la question mais je j'ai pas
de je crois pas que ça soit sa
préoccupation première du moment non on
en a pas parlé mais je le ressens comme
ça mais François baayerou il viendrait
éventuellement à ce poste ou un autre
parce que en tout cas l'éducation
nationale il y a un léger souci depuis
la nomination de de Madame oua casterra
les ennuis s'accumulent est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut changer de
locataire dans ce dans ce ministère la
ministre a fait des a fait des
maladresse a eu des propos qu'elle a
jugé elle-même maladroit elle s'en est
expliqué je crois maintenant qu'il faut
passer à autre chose et il faut lui
donner sa chance parce que c'est pas en
en continuant ceette sorte de bashing
antiamélie ou et Cera que ça va faire
avancer l'éducation nationale il y a des
sujets importants dans l'éducation
nationale mettons-nous tous au travail
collectivement pour avancer il y a un
sujet donc qui a été la crise agricole
qui a fait démarrer presque
naturellement la campagne des
européennes or beaucoup de partis ont
déjà leur tête de liste et vous dans la
majorité présidentielle on attend
toujours la vôre c'est vrai que ça fait
un petit peu étrange en tout cas d'avoir
d'un côté Jordan Bardella Marie toussin
chez les écologistes Raphaël Luxman
désormais et pour défendre le camp du
président personne est-ce que ce n'est
pas un problème soyons franc alors c'est
vrai queune incarnation arrive ça serait
bien faut pas que ça tarde mais on a
l'avantage nous sur l'Europe d'être
clair et d'avoir un projet européen
contrairement à d'autres partis où on
sait pas trop où ils sont sur l'Europe
on on sait pas s'ils sont pour s'ils
sont contre pour certains on sait qu'ils
sont franchement contre évidemment je
pense au rassemblement national mais
chez nous on a les gens les Français ont
une savent quelle est notre vision de
l'Europe c'est et donc la question de
l'Incarnation elle devra venir mais
c'est vrai que vous avez raison faut pas
que ça tarde maintenant mais il SAV où
vous êtes mais lorsqu'on voit les
enquêtes d'opinion on est à 4 mois du
scrutin AUD elles sont en train de
s'infléchir et elles remontent il y a un
effet Gabriel Atal il y a un effet
remanimement et il va falloir continuer
et bien c'est ce qu'on verra ou pas dans
les prochaine semaine merci beaucoup her
balanputé moderne du finister